question temps c'est le drame du ayong
ce cargo baptisé l'exodus vietnamien et
qui derrière le drame de 2564 réfugiés
cache la réalité d'un vietnam que nous
évoquerons tout à l'heure à travers le
reportage de jacques à bouchard après
leur reportage nous engagerons une
discussion entre des personnalités qui
manifestement n'ont pas le même point de
vue sur les raisons de ce drame
il s'agit de monsieur rené andrieu de
l'humanité d'andré glucksmann du docteur
bernard kouchner de madame von haye qui
s'occupe tous deux du comité français
pour un bateau pour le vietnam
j'ai discuté avec son qu'auditeur
pendent longuement assaillants
non je m'excuse non les îles noir je
m'excuse monsieur x man qui m'empêchera
de parler ici ce soir et on attend
d'ailleurs après je représente un grand
parti qui s'est battu banques allemandes
et pour la mère fait grincer dans la rue
je voulais amener ses dires les et vous
taisez vous cher monsieur je sais quand
vous appelez je sais que vous voulez
rire se taire je voudrais continuer les
poulets sont provocateurs et vous ne
représentez ici vous un meilleur si vous
êtes en place aujourd'hui
ce que je voudrais c'est bon mais que je
m'en veux parce que s'ils voyaient alors
moi je le dis aussi quelques ratés là je
suis moi dire et de répéter le couperet
des excuses s'il te plaît l'apport
habitudes et barnes l'avoir dit que j'ai
c'est un policier tout à l'heure où des
maladies vous n'avez pas eu je ne vais
rien dire ce que vous disiez je vais
regarder vous préférez garder les garder
ce qu'on pense que nous battions
ensemble à leurs annonceurs
dommage que tout ce temps de jaurès on
en parlera enfin les réfugiés
naturellement que l'on nommera sursis
aurait jamais sûr de rien
vous restez je ne reste pas en partir
aux individus ah ben voilà c'est la
démocratie
bon allez y est aussi attendue que je
vais derrière je dénonce l'opération
qu'abonné enfin à l'hôtel dieu parce que
les cendrieux parler depuis à moi rires
fusaient les c'est ma vie ce n'est pas
en fermant maintenant je n'ai pas
demandé non non non non sur le vietnam
c'est bien moi je ne reste pas avec
voilà elle vous a vu un seul le débat
n'aurait pas mérité passant landrieu